donald j trump is now president of the
united states
[Applause]
i have to say i'm not exactly sure why
we chose that as today's called open
it's just an oldie and a goodie and like
exactly what the internet is all about
when the internet is good and believe it
or not guys occasionally the internet is
good that is the good side of the
internet donald trump is now your
president
poor girl whatever happened her she's
probably a dude now that's probably what
ended up happening to her right it's got
to be it's got to be for sure uh i'm
dave rubin this is the reuben report
it's july 20th
2022 we're live streaming on rumble
youtube and blaze tv uh before i do
anything else i want to give a shout out
to my man max he is a viewer of the show
who reached out to us a couple months
ago when i had said it was still when i
was living back in dystopian california
in los angeles and i had said i had got
a gun we got some guns because we want
to protect the house because this place
is a dump and there's you know defunding
the police and there's crazy people uh
all you know wandering in front of my
house and all this stuff so we got some
guns uh and a whole bunch of people had
reached out to us uh offering to give us
some training and go shooting and all
sorts of stuff uh but max here in
florida reached out to us a while back
it was david's birthday yesterday we
took the whole team we went shooting
shooting our guns and then we got to
shoot an ak-47 and an ar-15 it was just
awesome it was just such a freaking fun
day in the free state of florida
shooting some stuff and it really was
just fantastic so thank you
max and today's show is going to be a
little different uh than our other shows
because um well some crazy things happen
that we'll show you up top but then
we're going to kind of shift it a little
bit to we'll do a little bit of a
mindset shift which is that you know
what i say you can't you can't take all
this stuff too seriously because it'll
make you crazy and that's why so many
people are crazy the people that that
sort of take politics and that is the
sum totality of the way they view the
world they're all sort of bananas but
you have to be able to look at this
stuff in a funny way right i think
hopefully that's at least partly why you
watch this show you have to be able to
laugh at some of the stuff not take it
so seriously uh you have to be able to
mock the hell out of these people and
everything else so we're gonna do some
mocking then we got some sort of offbeat
stories and then and then we got of
course some some good cleanup stuff at
the end about some of the things that
are going right i think you're gonna dig
it today uh before we get to any of that
let me talk to you guys about cozy earth
real quick i really love this stuff uh
you know hotter weather used to mean
goodbye to a good night's sleep until i
discovered cozy earth cozy earth bedding
is so soft luxurious and temperature
regulating i'm sleeping better than i
have in years listen there's a good
reason why cozy earth has thousands of
five-star reviews at cozyearth.com it's
truly awesome betting here's one from
lauren we literally just got them put on
our new bed yesterday and guys they are
incredible the sheets are worth every
penny cosy earth sheets made from 100
viscous from bamboo are now available in
four new natural colors and don't forget
their temperature regulating and very
breathable so you sleep cool and comfy
year round for a limited time save 35 on
cozy earth bedding be sure to check out
their ultra soft loungewear too i love
the sweatpants even though i'm here in
florida that's how soft and light they
are go to cozyearth.com
dave and save 35
off all backed by 100 night sleep
guarantee cozyearth.com
dave okay so first let's talk about the
squad some call them the jihad squad
some call them a bunch of crazy people
some call them woke lunatics but you
know these people this is aoc this is
ilhan omar this is rashida talib ayana
presley this is this group of democrat
progressives i'll even say the word it's
me it's a memeable day they're
regressives they're not progressives
there you go uh these are this is a
group of people who came in pretending
that they were democrats pretending that
they cared about america in some way but
they were they just had this righteous
indignation and they were loud and
people were sort of into it and they
became darlings of the media everyone
put them on every cover of every
magazine and they have basically
destroyed the democrat party they have
completely rotted the thing out from the
inside they are wildly anti-american i
don't think they care about any of our
founding documents they are socialists
they basically say they're socialists um
they're racist i would say there's just
absolutely no question that ilhan omar
and rashida talib especially uh racist
aoc is just an idiot who falls into
racism uh but the other two i think are
blatant racists um they are buffoons
they don't understand anything about
history okay yadda yadda yadda they're
bad chicks uh but the media loves them
because i don't know they're young or
something something like that right uh
well yesterday because uh they're not
happy about the supreme court decision
on roe v wade and when democrats are not
happy they get to protest at places and
burn things down and violently attack
things et cetera et cetera in this case
they protested uh over by congress uh by
the capitol over there and uh you know
some of them were arrested and they uh
they got into they busted out their
acting chops basically here's a little
video from cnn on what happened
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so there they are and you know you
can see the people in the back shut it
down because they're allowed to shut
things down when republicans do it means
a bunch of white supremacists are about
to assassinate the vice president and
yada yada okay fine um cnn actually lied
in that report there she was aoc was not
arrested she was removed temporarily she
was not arrested that's one thing the
other thing that's interesting about
this is that if you watch that video and
we're going to show you another version
of it in just a second
they all were pretending to be
handcuffed they were not handcuffed they
were all putting their hands behind
their back like this for the optics of
looking like police mean white
supremacist government agent police were
showing up and arresting them and
dragging them uh dragging them off that
is not what happened at all here is aoc
[Music]
[Applause]
she's not handcuffed there she's
pretending to be handcuffed she's also
got a big smile on her face uh this is
very similar to a week ago we showed you
that video where alex stein who's a
comedian was standing outside steps to
the capitol and he kept calling her big
booty aoc and she didn't hear it she
thought he was a fan she ran over with
the peace sign she's just an actress
that's what she is she is an actress
whose strings are being pulled by who
i'm not exactly sure but she's very
excited because she knows the optics as
she gallivants with her long strides and
her smug demeanor and her pretend i'm
being arrested
and she claimed she was arrested again
she was not arrested benny johnson who's
a friend of the show you've seen benny
he is a meme maker extraordinaire he
found the mug shot
that is a joke people that is just a
joke she was not in fact arrested my god
we should probably arrest her though
we've got more video here's ilhan omar
who is a racist lunatic defund the
police crazy person uh here's her being
fake arrested
[Applause]
she's not she has her hands behind the
back walking herself her hands are by no
there's nothing there she's holding her
own hands behind her back pretending to
be
arrested the this is it's such a perfect
like visual example of everything they
do they lie about everything there is
not one thing that they say or do
because they are so deep in the mire and
the muck of the lies that everything
they do they cannot do anything other
than lie and other than do things to
create theatrics so then when they do
that when they're doing this thing right
there and it's like when they're doing
it why so why are they doing it they
want the optics of we've been arrested
for peaceful protest except that's just
not what happened but that's what they
want you to think so that they can
further erode their brainwashed
audiences uh faith in the system because
they want to destroy the system that is
what they are here to do these people
are frauds and should be ignored and
exposed and by the way you have every
right to protest you have to protest
within the law
i don't know exactly what was going on
there that got the police involved you
know there are noise ordinances you
cannot block streets and traffic and
stop ambulance there are things around
that you cannot
protest outside of say a supreme court
justice's house with the intent to
intimidate them so there are some rules
but the democrats don't want any rules
anymore they have decided there should
be no rules well for us actually right
there are all sorts of rules for you
guys and if you guys trip over anything
if you trip over that imaginary line
that we're always moving we're going to
throw you guys in jail right that's what
we're going to do did you know this this
was probably the most underreported
story uh over the last couple days do
you guys remember dr simone gold she was
on this show she was one of the front
line doctors who was basically saying
you don't need the vaccine and masks
don't work and a whole bunch of other
stuff we had her on the show probably
about a year ago now i've met her in
person a couple times she was at the
capitol
on january 6. she gave a little speech
she was giving a speech in the capital
right she actually went into the
building she did not break anything she
did not punch anybody in the face she
didn't have a knife or a gun or anything
else but she gave a little speech there
she's now in jail i believe for 60 days
if i'm not mistaken she's going to be in
jail for 60 days this is a frontline
doctor who showed up at the capitol that
day to protest
i don't want to get into the january 6th
then because i think it's such a farce
but these these police officers and
security at the capitol they let them in
it's not to defend every action of every
single person but that's the that's the
point of all this that if you're on the
right let's say or you're just not a
crazy woke leftist progressive they will
treat you one way and then these people
aoc
and her jihad squad crazies they have to
pretend they're being arrested as
opposed to the people who actually get
arrested for protesting but if you think
that's crazy people we have a story
right now that i saw this yesterday and
i said guys we have to cover it and they
said are you sure dave is this is this
the type of thing we want to cover on
this program and i said we have to cover
this this is important this is vital
people need to know about this and we
have to talk about it so that it doesn't
happen again uh here's a tweet from the
new york post
arnold schwarzenegger deliberately
farted in my face
act actress claims
the woman being pictured there by the
way uh i'm told is only 23 years old but
that's what happened to her after
schwarzenegger farted in her face we've
got some more uh information from usa
today on exactly what happened this is
very important stuff people actress
miriam margulies knows how to hold a
grudge opening up about a foul
experience she had with former co-star
arnold schwarzenegger more than two
decades ago
during an appearance on the i've got
news for you podcast monday margulies
was asked by host andrew bucklow if
there were any celebrity co-stars she
didn't enjoy working with over the
course of her nearly 60-year career the
harry potter actress immediately brought
up schwarzenegger saying she didn't care
for him she explained he's a bit too
full of himself margulies and
schwarzenegger co-starred in 1999's at
end of days an apocalyptic horror film
about an ex-cop's quest to thwart
satan's search for a bride margulies
revealed schwarzenegger was rude to her
on set and that they had an unpleasant
encounter while filming
he farted in my face margulies told
bucklow now i fart of course i do but i
don't fart in people's faces he did it
deliberately right in my face
so you see
this is what's happening in society okay
and i think we can link this directly to
the progressives because you know arnold
schwarzenegger was a republican governor
in california and now he's pretty much a
democrat and what ha so you know you
just start farting on people's faces
i don't know exactly why we did that
story i just felt we had to people
needed to know people needed to know
because you know what it is i guess it's
the metaphor the left has been farting
in all of our faces and we have accepted
it
but that's it people we are not going to
let them fart in our face anymore
literally
or
figuratively but we've got more i told
you this is going to be an interesting
slightly different show uh with some of
this breaking type news it's it's wild
stuff uh that we're going to get to in
just a sec let me talk about talk to you
about real estate agents i trust you
guys know that buying or selling a home
is one of the most stressful things you
can do and it can be way worse if you're
not working with the right agent
generally speaking our homes are our
biggest investment which is a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
they work with only the best agents in
every market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their network and they only
work with full-time pros no part-time or
inexperienced agents their team makes
the introduction and then follows you
through the buying or selling process to
make sure that you're satisfied the
agents they work with have long track
records and are the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
just head on over to real estate agents
itrust.com today and provide them with
some info their team will contact you to
make an introduction to a preferred
agent in your town then you move to
florida shoot guns and live happily ever
after okay if arnold schwarzenegger
farting in this woman's face wasn't
enough wasn't my god dave i've heard
enough crazy stuff for one day well
we've still got more because do we have
the warning do we have the warning for
the people yes here's joy behar on the
view she's freaking out over climate
change supporting what the hell is wrong
with y'all don't you see what's
happening now they're waiting for the
eiffel tower to melt
because you know with runway our runway
in england is melting they cannot land a
plane yes
they're waiting for the eiffel tower to
melt i think she butchered a joke
perhaps that she was saying that the
water is going to raise so that
ultimately the sea level will engulf the
eiffel tower then she mentions this
raniere yes there was a hot runway
somewhere in england they don't have any
evidence that any of this has to do with
climate change these are the same crazy
people who 20 years ago 30 years 40
years ago you can look at all of the
headlines in newsweek and time magazine
and elsewhere that the big chill is
coming and we're going to go into a
global freeze and then temperatures went
up slightly and down a little bit more
and also couching all of that is the
idea that if you just gave these people
enough power if you just behaved a
little bit differently if you just used
a little bit of a different bag when you
went to whole foods that somehow the
environment would be okay or that a
bunch of these people who have never
accomplished anything these people who
are not industry leaders these people
who are not thought leaders these people
who are just bureaucrat nonsensical
usurpers of of your time and resources
if they just had more of your time and
resources then they could fix the
environment these people cannot tie
their shoes okay they cannot tie their
shoes they're just the worst but what is
their
answer to climate change because uh sure
i could say all that stuff but dave
could you really think this whole thing
is a farce could you really think that a
bunch of people who lie about everything
they wouldn't lie about this this is
serious stuff i mean sure they lied
about kovid they lie about literally
every public policy thing they call
everyone a racist every single thing
that they do is complete nonsense but
but climate change i mean dave please
what are you doing for god's sakes well
now they're pulling one out of their uh
basic uh simpsons movie situation you
remember the simpsons movie the plot of
the oh no wait that wasn't the simpsons
movie the simpsons movie
i'm crossing up two things it was a
simpsons episode where mr burns blocks
out the sun that was the
connor i'm blaming you on this one the
movie was about the dome we went through
this before the show the movie was about
the dome okay you all know about the
dome right
but the simpsons five part episode when
maggie who shot mr burns was because mr
burns blocked out the sun right he
blocked out the sun because he wanted to
burn slant drilling right so he could
make all the money uh well if you
thought that was crazy and that i
believe if i'm not mistaken i think i
was in college that was around 1994 mr
burns blocking out the sun well the
world economic forum's looking into it
we've got a tweet from the daily wire
should be no risk world economic forum
pushes space bubbles to block out the
sun
and stop climate change and there's of
course a picture of evil psycho leader
klaus
vader yeah not a good dude okay so they
are literally taking a plot from the
simpsons
from
roughly 30 years ago we are going to
block out the sun who is what is the
world economic forum why do these people
have any power over any of our
governments why do our leaders flock to
them and listen to them and and have i
mean none of it makes any sense uh and
again do you think that whether it's a
shield from the sun or a space bubble or
we put bubbles on the water to reflect
the sun back up so the oceans stay cool
do you think any of this works none of
it works it's all made up this is the
grift of griffs this is the higher you
know what the sun do you guys know about
the sun so the sun is this hot ball
okay it's a star and you maybe when you
were a kid you looked up at the stars
right you might have wished upon a star
okay
and there's a lot of stars carl sagan a
famous astronomer
and was he a physicist also he was an
astronomer at least he did cosmos of
course and wrote the movie contact one
of my favorite movies he used to talk
about billions and billions of stars
right that was
before memes he used to go on johnny
carson billions and billions and uh the
stars that are out there there's many of
them and actually our sun which is a
star is not that special it's just that
our earth our planet that we're on
happens to be close enough to it all the
conditions are right so that life was
able to start here
we now have a
conglomerate globalist group that would
like to block us from that thing that
thing that people have prayed to that
thing that creates light and life and
all of that stuff
that's what these freaks are interested
in i'm not a big fan of getting rid of
the sun okay just want to be rec uh very
very clear about that but there's more
there's more it's not just that they
want to get rid of the sun
here is alibaba group president j
michael evans at the world economic
forum talking about how once they get
rid of the sun they have other plans for
you
we're developing
through technology an ability for
consumers to measure their own carbon
footprint
what does that mean that's
where are they traveling how are they
traveling what are they eating what are
they consuming on the platform
so individual carbon footprint tracker
stay tuned we don't have it operational
yet but this is something that we're
working on
i mean that is some death star level
[ __ ]
this thing's not fully operational but
we're gonna make it fully operational
but as you guys know there's always a
way to blow up a death star and that's
what i'm here to do michael liked that
one um what what did you hear what he
said who what when where we're gonna
track you where you are who you are when
you are all of those things at your
carbon footprint and what you're doing
online
what is going on here people i just am
not interested in this i'm not
interested in this and i guess i have to
destroy these people
i have nothing better to do i really
don't i have a lot going on i do have a
lot going on i have a busy day you guys
see my calendar i have a lot going on
every day even today i have to go to the
physical therapist it's not that i have
nothing to do i just feel that i have to
save the world
just in me
annoying as hell sometimes i gotta tell
you um
anyway
all of this this craziness we're gonna
block the sun we're gonna track where
you are we're gonna pretend to get
arrested we're gonna fart in your face
you see the connection that i'm making
on all this stuff
it's all sort of cover for this inept
bumbling buffoon who is pretending to be
president of the united states uh so
we've got some video here this is
coordinator for strategic communications
of the white house john kirby and he's
uh covering for joe biden who's been
missing since he's been back from the
middle east one more on the so i noticed
on the president's schedule last two
days are there been no public events is
he resting after the
large international trips the
president's been busy i'll let kareem
speak to the president's schedule but
the president's been quite busy just
because you don't see
something necessarily on the public
schedule doesn't mean that there's not a
lot of work going on
no he's not there's just no chance he
got back from this disastrous trip this
trip could not have gone worse short of
short of like literally starting world
war three right this trip could not have
gone worse the bumbling talking about
honoring the holocaust uh the the fist
bump with mbs after he was not gonna
meet with him this thing was a disaster
basically begging the saudis for oil
while we're shutting off our own oil
just the whole thing was a freaking
disaster not knowing where he is shaking
imaginary hands he's old and tired and
confused and they are running him into
the grave literally so he's obviously
been resting for these 48 hours and by
the way for any of you that have ever
been to europe
when you come back you're a little
jet-lagged
phoenix you were in you were in italy
couple was about two months ago did you
need a little rest when you came back a
little bit of rest a couple extra hours
of sleep okay we've all done it we've
all gone from coast to coast you could
be a little bit tired so i would grant
him 48 hours of laying in the tomb that
they put him in at night and then they
bring him up and they inject him with
all the stuff and they get him out there
i'd be fine with that
but they can't be honest about anything
oh jean crin we've got the black lesbian
she'll explain where the dead man is
but what is really going on here now i
can link this all together between
farting in the face between the eiffel
tower melting between blocking out the
sun between hiding the old bastard
here's a tweet from el american about
what might actually be going on here
over the next couple days because they
realized they needed to ramp up the fear
the covet fear is not working anymore
the biden administration is expected to
seize emergency powers by the end of the
week with an announcement that the
climate crisis
demands immediate executive action
okay
this is legit this is their next move
and by the way many people have been
talking about this
they are going to ramp up climate change
because they realize they are running
out of cards the thing the biden thing
broke down so quickly and became so
obvious so quickly and they can't censor
us all fast enough and god only knows
what else is in there is their bag of
tricks but now they have to ramp it up
again because i think they're realizing
even in the last week where they're
ramping up covet again and parts of cali
are gonna put masks on and all that
stuff they're realizing that too many
people are just not going to do it so
how the hell can we really scare them
well the sun is going to either crash
into the earth
the water is going to boil we're going
to melt buildings all hell is going to
break loose and only if you give the old
man who literally doesn't know where he
is more power through executive actions
he will somehow stop the environment
from environmenting that's how we're
going to do it
here's a black lesbian explaining what's
going on
a public health emergency as i just laid
out
and so we're just we're just
still moving forward with um with the
options that we potentially have
in front of us everything is on the
table but declaring a public health
emergency is very different from
declaring a climate emergency each
unlocks a different set
of authorities and a different pot of
funding
oh
so we're going to declare a public
health emergency and she'll get to
unlock some stuff and take some more
money and do some more stuff and grow
the government but if she really went
all the way right with the elderly guy
they'd do a climate emergency and then
they could unlock other stuff and have
more money and guess what that's coming
too
there is no emergency it's all nonsense
we can talk about what is going on with
the environment and that it warms up
sometimes and cools off sometimes but
why don't they tell you about any of the
good news might i recommend you go to a
site called human progress uh i've had
the bjorn i'm blanking on his last name
actually uh bjorn lumberg right
on the show a couple times
from human progress and
humanprogress.org they do a great job
showing you about all of the good things
that are happening right now that there
is less famine than ever before that
there is more green on the earth than
ever before that the global rates of
poverty are way low that more people
have risen to the middle class and all
of that stuff but they don't want you to
know any of that what they want you to
think is that only
if you give these people who are not
good people
more of your everything they want it all
guys they want it all
if you give them all of that control
over your life and they can track where
you are and they can turn on the sun and
turn off the sun and tell you when to go
out and lock you in the metaverse and
all of those things and i know this all
sounds crazy but it's all true
it's all true
uh then things will be okay um but it's
not just that she's unlocking certain
things now and they're going to unlock
other things later
they also want and again this was all
stuff that two years ago you would have
been told you were complete conspiracy
theorists for this is the type of stuff
that made people watch alex jones and
they go alex jones is bananas what do
you mean there's a global thing
happening there's a global one-world
government and they're going to
coordinate together and somehow it'll be
above the united states this is the type
of stuff that would get banned people
banned
years ago
and now they're just blatantly admitting
it right from in front of us here is
korean jean-pierre talking about the
globalist plan
senator manchin is rejecting the the
global tax deal that secretary ellen
negotiated with like 100 plus countries
um what will happen if those countries
move ahead with the deal in the u.s
so i have a couple of things on a couple
points on that that i wanted to share
with all of you so we remain committed
to finalizing a global minimum tax it
will level the playing field as you all
know for u.s businesses
decrease incentives to move jobs
offshore and close loopholes that
cooperations have used to shift profits
overseas
yeah okay none of that will work there's
always ways to get around taxes and also
i'm pretty sure
i'm a simple guy so sometimes i forget
about these things but i'm pretty sure
that when i voted i voted for say my
mayor and i voted for my governor and i
voted for my president but i didn't vote
for a global
organization
a global organization that was going to
decide what the tax rates are all over
the world i don't remember voting for
that do you guys remember voting for no
nobody so that's weird i guess we should
probably be you know just put that in
your little
you know just put that up there keep
that in mind that we never voted for any
of this uh and the idea that any of this
would work to do any of those things and
that that these clowns who have wrecked
our economy no if we just have a global
minimum tax then things will be better
for uh for american companies i mean
it's just silly drivel absolute silly
drivel and speaking of silly dribble
here's gay pete now gay pete of course
as you know is the transportation
secretary never had any experience doing
transportation he was the mayor of south
bend indiana very small town not it's
unclear to me whether he had a car even
uh he did once get caught they wanted an
uh a video of him riding a bike and then
he of course got caught because they put
him in a truck with the bike and then
they took him somewhere and then he got
on the bike but they wanted to make it
seem like he's a real big biker because
he's a transportation guy he's
completely inept he took a few months
off for paternity leave while all of the
supply chain stuff was going down um he
is he is nothing he is just a suit with
nothing in it he is pretending he speaks
with the same affect as barack obama i
mean they're just training him he's the
perfect he's sort of like a young obama
a young
biden it's just like you're a suit
that's part of the machine you stand for
nothing but you always say the thing
that the machine wants you to say but
then we have a real
congressman this is thomas massey of
kentucky and uh he's grilling gay pete
on what's going on here with all this
electric car nonsense the average uh
household uses 17 percent of their
electricity for air conditioning
and
that would mean the average household
uses
1
870 kilowatt hours per year for air
conditioning if that average household
plugged in electric cars
do you know how much more electricity
they would use in comparison to the air
conditioning that air conditions their
whole house no but again i would
emphasize it let me help you let me help
you with that first before we go on
because the numbers are important it
would take four times as much
electricity to charge the average
households cars as the average household
uses on air conditioning do you think
that could be so if we reach the goal by
2030 that biden has of a 50 adoption
instead of 100 adoption that means the
average household would use twice as
much electricity charging
one of their cars as they would use for
all of the air conditioning that they
use for the entire year do you think
this could contribute to
rolling uh blackouts and brownouts in
areas of the country where air
conditioning is basically considered
essential not if we prepare look the
fact that people who have electric
vehicles are going to use more
electricity can't be a reason to give up
the idea that america is inferior to the
other countries that have figured this
out just doesn't sit well with us in
administration that's why we're
investing i have a better grid god pete
is so deeply inauthentic even his accent
feels fake right everything about him
feels fake but thomas massey you might
be watching thomas maxine go dave you're
showing me a congressman from kentucky
he must be backwards he must power his
car with moonshine he's from the south
uh actually thomas massey has owned an
electric vehicle for nearly 10 years
and i have the image on my phone right
here and we're going to put it in in
post so you will see it when you watch
this clip and you can google it yourself
he turned a tesla model s
battery into a home power system for
himself because i think he's also an
electric engineer if i'm not mistaken
okay so this is a guy who believes in
electric energy this is not some
anti-technology person this is not some
crazed fossil fuel lobbyist okay this is
a guy who believes in actual science and
all of those things but what he's saying
is you government stooges gay pete don't
know what you're doing you're telling
people they're gonna save money but
they're actually not gonna save money
and i have the evidence right here and
pete basically says
yeah you know a certain amount of pain
and if you just give us enough power
we'll figure out how to deal with it uh
and here's pete going even a little bit
deeper this is a while back but it's
been getting the it's been making the
rounds again over the last couple days
uh p basically admitting that the pain
related to all of this is actually the
point of course the more pain we are all
experiencing from the high price price
of gas the more benefit there is for
those who can access electric vehicles
did he just say that i think we might
have to show that again because that
would be an odd thing for a government
official to say we're intentionally
hurting you people that seems odd of
course the more pain we are all
experiencing from the high price price
of gas the more benefit there is for
those who can access electric vehicles
do
you
get it yet
the pain is the point when they tell you
that it is putin's price hike it is a
lie
they are intentionally
increasing the price of gas not going to
our reserves not unleashing american
energy properly because they want the
price to be high and why do they want
the price to be high so that you will
get off that car and you will get one of
their electric vehicles now i am not
against electric vehicles i have a tesla
it's freaking awesome i drove us all
yesterday to the gun range was it fun
being back there you guys were watching
netflix there's a little little tv
screen back there pretty great
um i only let them watch the kids shows
by the way what were you watching i was
uh
paw patrol you love that paw patrol um
i'm not against electric vehicles the
tesla is absolutely awesome although uh
tesla which obviously does get some
government subsidies too is not always
on the list of uh companies that the
government really wants to help because
the biden administration obviously does
not love elon musk that's a separate
issue altogether this has nothing to do
with whether electric vehicles are good
or bad the point is the government is
actively telling you
because 90 percent of americans can't
afford an electric vehicle right they
just can't and things things change over
time remember remember what it was 15
years ago if you were buying a 42 inch
flat screen tv i remember i bought my
first samsung 42 inch flat screen tv i
must have bought it around 2008
something like that i remember cost 2
500 i had virtually no money i bought it
on a pc richards uh payment plan which
it ended up costing me like five
thousand bucks because of all the
interest i racked up on that stupid
thing but the point is things cost a lot
and then over so rich people afford them
first right vcrs used to cost a lot
dvd players blu-ray players whatever
things cost a lot at first a certain
amount of more wealthy people get them
that then allows more of them to be made
the cost go down this is basic economics
and then more people can afford it what
they are doing is artificially gaming
the system right now and saying it
doesn't matter whether you can afford or
not we are going to hurt the hell out of
you and what's interesting even more
interesting about it is so they're
hurting the hell out of you by making
you pay more for gas as if suddenly
you'll just magically be like oh you
know what
sure i i have this hyundai and you know
it's only five years old but the gas is
so much and i really can't afford
anything else but but pete gay pete
wants me to get an electric car and i'm
gonna go do it because it gave pete we
have a meme of gay pete
you can't afford eight dollar a gallon
gasoline then buy a 50 000 car you
[ __ ] idiot i love that one i love
that one so put the smile on that one
they just really nailed that one put
that back up for a sec
i mean it's just this is what it is this
is the government we are hurting you we
smile this i am this is my barack obama
sleeves up no jacket pose and buy a car
because yes you are a [ __ ] idiot okay
so how do we win how do we win i think
this show's sort of dancing around that
we win with laughter and making fun of
these people and exposing it and all of
that stuff you you know it uh if we if
we are just lighter if we are happier
and more joyous and more productive
because that also comes along with it
then uh
then they will see it they will see it
and it doesn't mean that they will come
with us but we will
we will show them the way and perhaps
some of them will come with us and you
know what also happens the the endless
misery and the larping live-action
role-playing that aoc
and ilhanomar and all them were doing
and the endlessly being outraged of
things and pretending you're in
hands-made tale and pretending that the
world's gonna end it does it it cannot
run forever right it can't because
people can't it's not in the human
condition to be able to run on that
level of insanity for that long laughter
is the best medicine meaning when you
see it and you laugh at it you realize
these people are ridiculous and you go
live your life that's how we defeat it
so what's happening is as the as the
hysteria around it sort of
dissipates because they can't maintain
it at that level even the people who
ushered in this ridiculous president
this horrible administration who have
pretended everyone else were racist who
taught pretended the squad were decent
people even they now are realizing they
better start making fun of some of this
stuff or they're going to be left in the
dust so here's jimmy fallon i have no
particular feelings about jimmy fallon
he's the nbc tonight show host the
tonight show is a long way away from the
johnny carson tonight show or the jack
park tonight show before that
or the steve allen tonight show before
that i know my history of comedy um
here's jimmy fallon who is obviously a
lefty he's just like a corporate like
you got to just be a sort of corporate
nothing to get on nbc late night okay is
what it is he's making a lot of money
probably a decent guy actually remember
when he touched donald trump's hair
remember that years ago he had donald
trump and he touched his hair and then
they tried to cancel him because you
can't make donald trump look like a
human that's that's literally what
they're saying you're humanizing him
you're humanizing that man
anyway here's jimmy fallon realizing
that the tide's turning so he better
start making fun of biden
let's get to some news on friday
president biden held a controversial
meeting with the crown prince of saudi
arabia but the real controversy was that
biden greeted him with a fist bump
watch this watch this
yeah
biden said that wasn't a fist bump that
was me trying to punch him as hard as i
could
not a great look it's like a greeting
putin with a chest bump and a bro hug my
man what are you doing
meanwhile i read that dr fauci said that
he plans to retire by the end of
president biden's term
and then everyone turned to biden like
is there anything you'd like to announce
too
of course once he's gone fast you will
be replaced by a new slightly weaker
variant
okay fine like that's comedy to some
degree i didn't laugh i thought the
street fighter fist thing was kind of
funny um but somebody might have laughed
at that but the point is that the
average person that watches these shows
they might it might start bubbling in
their brain oh maybe joe biden is very
old and confused maybe these fist bumps
instead of handshakes don't make any
sense maybe he should retire because
fouchy's getting out so maybe something
good here is happening that is the point
and then i thought this one was this is
great like this and this is true it is a
joke and it is true this is a tweet from
newsmax this is just spectacular the
place where president joe biden fell off
his bicycle last month in rehoboth beach
delaware has been listed as a historical
landmark called brandon falls
on google maps the washington examiner
reported on tuesday like
that's it people that literally is how
we win
i really believe it there will be some
political answers too and you got to
vote for the right people and you got to
live in states that have a chance and
you've got to leave states that don't
have a chance but that's how we'll win
that really is how we'll win i really
that's how the culture thing will get
won we lost this
because decent people lost the culture
but we can win this by decent people
grabbing the culture back uh we got a
cold clothes for you in a moment do we
have locals comments today
we have some locals comments today
i'll give you five seconds for some oh
they're coming here they go uh here we
go
snowbaby89 says democrats can't make up
their mind on what they want to freak
out the most
uh on fast enough they're manic and how
quickly they jump from crisis to crisis
right and and once you see that that's
why i'm always talking about you got to
just see it and that's why i always go
back to old clips because once you see
hey
they had us crazy about covid now they
need us crazy about uh the climate and
guess what they used to have us crazy
about y2k remember y2k a long time ago
they keep you crazy from thing to thing
but that cannot if you are sane if you
are grounded if you understood that the
story of being a human has happened
before and it's gonna happen again and
you're just a little piece of the puzzle
and to just do the best you can within
that if you get that they will not make
you crazy and that's what they fear the
most because if you are not crazy you
will they you will realize you don't
need them
and then what are they if you don't need
them they are nothing remember that end
of uh b for vendetta we when uh prime
minister suttler he's basically saying
we have to show them how much they need
us
what if we don't need them
captain america
says could this be the captain america
incredible uh they defunded the police
so the cops didn't have any money for
handcuffs oh maybe that was their move
all along they defunded the police so
that they could protest so that they
could disturb the public and then the
police would not be able to handcuff
them so they i mean larpers they're
larpers google larping if you haven't
seen any larping videos this is where a
bunch of like bearded sort of asexual
weirdos pretend that they're like in you
know 1700 england oh though doubt dope
and they've got their little fake
little cardboard swords and they poke
each other and no no it's very weird but
that's basically what aoc is at this
point uh talway says i find it actually
heartening that since the left has gone
so far off the rails former gun control
libs like dave and tim poole have come
to understand why the founding fathers
put the second amendment in the
constitution yeah well thank you and by
the way
it's not just us there are so many
people tim pool is another is the right
example on this tim and i we both
described ourselves as disaffected
liberals right tim and i also sort of
grew together i would say you know in
this online world whatever this thing is
and tim's huge right now and and part of
that is we were trying to put the brakes
on the leftist insanity uh but at the
same time we were willing to have the
conversations with the conservatives
what happens to a lot of liberals is
they can they can call out a degree of
the leftist stuff but they they're still
afraid of conservatives and because i
wasn't and because i don't think tim is
uh i think it's why our thoughts doesn't
mean we're right about everything
obviously but it's why there's you know
what i think
and and
in a case of going shooting yesterday uh
which we took the whole team to go
shooting and it was fun and it was
awesome and it was a you know when
you're when you're doing it and you're
out there you're like man it is
important to be able to defend myself
listen i live in miami florida we have a
great police department here i've got a
great mayor i have a phenomenal governor
we did have an incident at the house the
cops were here in about two minutes they
were they were nice several of them knew
me it's all good but you still want to
be able to defend yourself you still
want that so defending the second
amendment defending the first amendment
hey defending all those amendments i
think it's good and yeah the crazier
they get i think they can get more
people to realize that too uh you can
always play along during the show by
joining us at reubenreport.locals.com
and don't forget we have an apple ios
app and we've got a google
play app for the android uh my full
miami improv interview with christina
pushad
governor ron desantis press secretary is
out this sunday is that right it's out
this sunday why
tomorrow
tomorrow on youtube and rumble
yeah and guess what it's up on vocals
already so there you go
all right and uh we've got a cold
clothes for you today uh we started with
a crazy person screaming when donald
trump was announced president it was a
very scary day for a lot of people we
leave you
with the woman who could be president if
joe biden can't get to the finish line
have a good one
i think that to be very honest with you
i i do believe that we
should have rightly believed but we
certainly believe that certain issues
are just settled
all signs point to good work having
happened but more work to get done
what the hell just happened